okay our last talk of the morning will
be a Neiman re and he will tell us all
about many uses of stable polynomials hi
everyone so this is based on joint works
with Shia Novus there and the reserves
ie I mean so very and might sink I must
admit that I I sort of did a
bait-and-switch a little bit I'm not
gonna be able to cover everything that
was in the abstract but I tried to make
the talk a gentle introduction to
basically all of the ideas behind these
connections that have been found between
stable polyols and counting an
optimization problem so let me start by
this example so let's say that I want to
count spanning trees in a graph does
anybody know how many spanning trees
this graph has 16 all of them okay so
let's say I pick an edge E and I count
the number of spanning trees that
contain this edgy now what's the number
hey hey perfect I've highlighted them I
don't know if you can see I was guessing
what what is it so so you know this the
fraction of the spanning trees that
contain the edge E is you can you can
interpret it probabilistically as if
you're picking a random spanning through
you're trying to see what's the
probability that your edge E is in the
spanning tree this is known in many
communities by many names you know if
you're thinking about the random
spanning tree distribution this would be
the marginal probability of H E it's
sometimes known by the leverage score or
you know if your graph is unweighted
this is also equal to the effective
resistance between the two endpoints of
the edge e don't worry about if don't
worry about it if you don't know what
that means but this connection lets you
compute these quantities in polynomial
time
so all right so these marginals of the
edges I want to use them as features
encoding my graph so I will not compute
the marginals of the edges and I want to
throw away my graph and I want to see
what I can tell about the graph based on
these margins so for example for this
graph I translate it to a set of six
numbers all of them equal to one half
this would be like how for each edge you
do this yes for you judging my graph I
do this and I'm doing with unweighted
graph okay so all right so so this graph
for this graph you know what the margins
are but let's say there is an unknown
graph whose marginals I tell you are
exactly four ones yes first let's start
with something simpler
what's the number of edges obviously
it's for the number of elements in my
set what's the number of vertices
five basically if you sum up all of
these marginals you're gonna get the
number of edges in a spanning tree which
is just the number of vertices minus one
right if I add one plus that stool some
I get the number of rare disease so how
many spanning trees does this graph have
you should be able to answer this one
right do I know the complete graph based
on these know could be any spanning tree
but it could be any tree with four eight
this is now let's do a more complicated
example what if the marginals were these
quantities okay can you tell me what the
number of spanning trees is a possible
answer yes but that's not the only
answer
okay so 16 you get by adding two
dangling edges to the original graph
that I started with
there is another graph which has exactly
the same marginals you have parallel
edges the parallel edges have effective
resistance one half and these two edges
have effective resistance one so in this
graph the number of spanning trees is
eight okay so obviously I can't
determine exactly what the number of
spanning trees is based on these
marginal
but let's say that I want to find bounds
on these things okay so here is here is
here's a very crude upper bound and you
can get paste based on the marginals
it's based on the entropy method so
let's say that T is a uniformly random
spanning tree okay what we want is the
number of values it can take right you
can clearly write the log of that number
as the entropy of this random variable
is is the definition of entropy
who knows who doesn't know what the
entropy is okay good
so so if you have a discrete random
variable the Shannon entropy of it is
defined as like this formula I've
written it down for the spanning trees
here sorry I've written it down for the
spanning trees here and if your variable
if your random variable takes n distinct
values uniformly at random the entropy
of it is going to be log n and so isn't
it you have H of T shouldn't be this is
the calligraphed because well sure this
is a random variable though I mean you
can write the entropy of a random
variable okay our graffiti is the set of
all spanning trees
okay so we know that entropy is sub
additive okay meaning that if you have a
bunch of random variables the entropy of
the joint where an variable is less than
the sum of the entropies so if I look at
whether each edge II was in my spanning
tree or not those would be variables
whose Joint Distribution is the same as
the distribution of T and it clearly has
the same entropy so the entropy of the
spanning random spanning tree is less
than the sum of the entropies of the
edges okay
for each edge I can compute these on
trapeze because I know what the
probability of that edge appearing and
then the random spanning three is now
what's surprising is that four spanning
tree is this this inequality that I
showed you is tied up to a factor of two
so for a second let's believe that and
see what it gives for these marginals
that we were working with so you know I
have six edges each of them have one bit
of entropy so the total entropy I get
here is six so it's telling me that the
number the entropy of my spanning tree
is between three and six which means
that the number of spanning trees is
between 8 and 64
we already saw an example with eight
spanning trees so at least this
inequality is tight
questions before I move on so I wanna I
want to show you a proof of this fact
okay it's it's basically the only proof
I have time to to do completely okay so
you know we want to show that the
entropy is bigger than half the entropy
of the Sun half the sum of the entropies
sorry I've written the sum of the
entropy of each of these random
variables it's a boolean random variable
so it's entropy is just P log 1 over P
plus 1 minus P log 1 over log 1 over 1
minus P now if I want to show that - I
saw entropy is bigger than this sum I
can clearly it's clearly enough to show
that the entropy is bigger than this sum
and it's also bigger than this so ok so
I'm going to show you the first one
so here is where things get tricky we
are gonna use polynomials and for
spanning trees there is a there is a
very useful polynomial called the
generating polynomial so think of this
as a polynomial over for each edge of
the spanning tree you have one variable
for each spanning tree you have a
monomial which is the product of the
variables associated to the edges and
then you sum this over all spanning
trees in your graph it's the definition
clear all right now the only thing I'm
going to use in this proof is that this
polynomial is law concave over the
positive numbers it's log is concave
as a function it's log is concave
so you know if you have a concave
function what's the best way of deriving
in your call inequalities based on it
it's by using yen since inequality and
that's what I'm gonna do so let's define
a random variable Y which is just some
scaling of the indicator vector of my
spanning tree okay so my spanning tree
has some indicator vector I'm going to
rescale it so that its expectation
becomes the old ones vector so I'm going
to define I'm gonna divide each
coordinate by its expectation the
probability of that edge appearing in
the tree now this my variable its
expectation is the all ones variable now
if I apply the in sense inequality on it
I get this so piensan just says that you
can move the expectation outside and you
get a smaller quantity okay
so let's compute these two sides I I
made the variable y have the expectation
all one's right so the left-hand side is
just the log of my polynomial value that
the all one's vector which is clearly
the number of spanning trees so on the
left-hand side I get the log of the
number of spanning trees what do I get
on the right-hand side I claim that I
get exactly this this first summand
let me actually write it down because I
hear so what's a log of G of Y it's
going to be so my Y vector is going to
be some scaled version of the the
indicator vector of a spanning tree
right so only one of these terms is
going to survive right only the term
corresponding to that spanning tree is
going to survive and this is going to be
the sum over all edges in T of my
scalings log of my scaling
there's only one monomial surviving I'm
taking the lock so I can't the monomial
becomes the sum right and I get the log
of one over whatever whatever my scaling
was which was one over P okay now I'm
taking the expectation of this over why
so now I have two for each edge II look
at how many times it appears or in with
what probability it appears in this sum
and that's exactly the probability that
the edge e appears in my spanning tree
so this expectation is going to be the
sum over all edges of PE log 1 over GE
and that's the end of the proof at least
for proving that the entropy is at least
this sum okay now what do I do with the
other part well for the other part you
have to look at the complement of
spanning trees okay
now you're dealing with some strange
objects but they still satisfy all of
these properties if you can define a
generating polynomial for them which can
which can even be derived from the
generating polynomial of spanning trees
and the generating formula is still
going to be LA concave and you can prove
the same things except when you're
looking at the complement you're
switching P with 1 minus P but the
complement has the same entropy as the
as the tree right so I get the other
side of the inequality
the only thing I haven't shown you in
this proof was why was that generating
polynomial are concave and that that
takes us to real instability right so
you know in the in the previous talk you
in the previous talks of today you you
saw some definitions of real stability
and hypervelocity I'm gonna just remind
you a polynomial multivariate
polynomials just real stable if if you
restrict it to any univariate direction
which has positive components which is
positive slope basically then it must be
real rooted okay so any univariate this
restriction of your polynomial is real
rooted if and only if the polynomial is
real stable that's the definition of
real stability another way of saying
this thing is your polymer is hyperbolic
with respect to every positive direction
now in the previous talk you you saw
that the poem you're a hyperbolic yes it
is true yes because a subset of a subset
of these distributions is also satisfies
conditions yeah
so the generating polynomial
it's hyperbola silicon contains the
positive or thent right it has
non-negative coefficients it's never
zero on here and in the in the previous
talk you saw that the polynomial log of
it is a concave barrier for the
hyperbola silicon which means that the
log of G is concave all over this place
which includes the positive or cent as
well questions on that
so that was first shown by guarding yeah
so I I proved this to you for spanning
trees and their compliments but what is
a more general statement the more
general statement can only be said after
i define strongly riley measures for you
so you know spanning this tree
distribution is roughly a distribution
on a subset of the hypercube okay you're
just looking at whether the edges are in
the spanning tree or not in general if
you have a random variable taking values
in the hypercube or equivalently a
distribution on the hypercube you can
again assign a generating polynomial to
this distribution the coefficients are
going to be the probabilities and for
each possible value the random variable
is taking you have a monomial okay this
which powers are exactly the zero ones
so this is the generating poem you know
same as before a stronger iid measure is
exactly a measure who is polynomial is
real stable that's the definition okay
and the key thing is that spanning three
distributions have this property here
are the famous examples of such
distributions if you have independence
Bernoulli's so if you're taking an
independent distribution on the
hypercube you are going to be getting a
real stable polymer more generally if
you have a determinant of distribution
so think of this as you have some
vectors in some high dimensional space
and you're taking each subset of the
vectors with probability proportional to
the volume spanned by them squared
probability of occurrence is
proportional to N squared of VI sinus so
this is a determinant of distribution
the term rental distributions are
slightly more general than this but this
case contains most of their uses
spanning-tree distributions are actually
a special case of this where you take
your vectors to be where you take your
vectors to be the the plus 1 minus 1
vectors from which you construct the
laplacian of the graphs for example yeah
let me not dive into that ok so these
are all examples of strangulated
distributions for which our inequality
holds so the inequality instead of
counting now you have to deal with the
entropy of the whole stronger
distribution you can approximate the
entropy of the strongly related
distribution within a factor of 2 by the
sum of the entropies that's what it says
you can also get an additive error
approximation and explain that by
writing another inequality here
so we saw two inequalities one was that
this is true and the other one was that
this is true now the thing is that if
you have a distribution supported on 0-1
vectors whose l1 norm is some some
number and this is at most n or I can I
can even yeah you know I did it more
clearly so this thing over here is at
most the sum of the pies
two trivial inequality to show so so the
gap between the entropy of my joint
variable and the sum of the entropies is
bounded by this quantity which is at
most of some of the PI's right so for a
spanning tree is the sum of the PI's is
always n minus 1 so my so so this thing
is also giving me an additive
approximation to the entropy and the
Devourer is at most end sometimes the
additive approximation is better
sometimes the multiplicative
approximation is better it totally
depends on your taste complement is
always you can basically derive the
complement by inverting the variables
and then multiplying the polynomial by
something so just pure the algebraic
operations that preserve the condition
on the roots
so back to counting you know I've shown
you that if you give me the marginals
from the uniform distribution and on a
strongly Riley set then I can count the
set approx okay but usually computing
these marginals is as hard as counting
the counting problem that you're dealing
with in the beginning right so how do i
how do I avoid this problem of computing
these marginals and still get an
approximation to to my counting problem
the solution is to max just maximize
over all feasible marginals okay so let
me let me briefly explain this so I know
that my marginals must satisfy some
inequalities in particular they must be
in the convex hull of my the indicator
vectors of my set okay because any
distribution of my set has marginals in
this convex hull that's the definition
of the convex hull and I know that this
these marginals coming from the uniform
distribution are you know some point in
this comic so okay I don't know which
point it is I just take the maximum sum
of marginals for any feasible point here
and I claim that it's still gonna give
you the same approximation factor 2 or
additive or P depending on your taste
okay so the requires that you have a
distribution so I'm here assuming that
the base distribution is uniform the
base distribution who which gives you a
real stable polynomial is uniform that's
why I said strongly set not the strong
distribution but anyways so I'm assuming
the yeah the uniform distribution is the
strong really measure but I don't have
access to to the polynomial itself or so
if I want to solve this max in a
maximization problem the only thing I
need to have is a separation Oracle for
this polytope okay if you are dealing
with let's say some weird Metroid you
might have access to this but not the
polynomial defining the the generating
polynomial of the matrix okay so that's
why this this thing is sometimes
feasible while you don't have access to
the counting problem
now let me just prove that this gives
you the same approximation factor
feasible marginal yours literally just
that it's in this sentence that it's not
implied but they think that any set of
marginal is actually induces some
distribution of Hispanic troops so any
marginal in this set gives you some
distribution in the spanning trees
that's true because any point here can
be written as a convex combination of
the vertices the vertices are spanning
trees okay yes that is true but what's
not clear is that you can you can
actually write any point here as a as
the marginals of a stronger distribution
supported on these vertices there might
be some of your distribution
so so far the only one we know is rally
is the uniform one yes yeah and you're
saying if we knew the marginals for the
uniform distribution we would sort of be
done but if the if the margins were yeah
yeah but even if you don't know them by
solving this maximization problem you
get the same approximation yeah well
provided you get something that's
probably Rayleigh right what do you mean
so that's what I'm gonna actually prove
that this P is always as so you know so
let's let's start with a very complex
convex program let's say that I
maximizing overall distributions
supported on my settee of the entropy of
this distribution
okay so if you if you have if you if you
have another distribution then somehow
that doesn't correspond to the polytope
anymore the polytope doesn't capture
anything about the weights of my
distribution right so you can change
this entropy by the relative entropy if
you if you allow your distribution to be
proportional to the product of weights
of the elements but I could have some
crazy distribution that's not like that
so yeah back here so let's say I
maximize over that issue overall
distribution supported on my set of the
entropy of that distribution does
anybody know what the answer to this is
yes the uniform distribution always has
the maximum entropy and it's going to be
the log of the size of my set right now
I can write this maximum entropy program
as you know I break it down into two
parts first I fix the marginals of this
distribution and then I ever all
distributions was marginals RP
any distribution must have some
marginals I just you know broke down
this maximization into two parts now the
thing that that I'm not going to prove
but is true is that if you fix our
marginals the maximum entropy
distribution that has those marginals
is going to be given by something like
this the probability of each spanning
three T is going to be proportional to
the product of some lambda ease very
ease in the tree so you can always find
some lambdas associated to the edges
such that the probability of each
spanning tree is just the proportional
to this product okay this is roughly
true because the constraints you're
putting are fixing the marginals and
these lambdas are somehow devolved to
the constraints you're putting on this
convex program if I knew that my uniform
distribution was strongly Riley this
distribution is also stronger ID because
what's the generating polynomial of this
distribution you're just scaling each
variable of your initial palm you know
by just some lambda
so so the thing that I get here is going
to be stronger Riley therefore its
entropy is going to be well approximated
by the entropy I get from just the
marginals the sum of the entropies of
the marginals therefore this gives me
the same approximation
it's in your program your you're not
maximizing the entropy subject oh I'm
just I'm just making sure that my
margins is in the convex health in the
convex hull and this becomes a
deterministic function of the marginals
which is the optimal solution of this is
not I mean once you fix the marginals
you can always find a stronger ID
distribution that satisfies those
marginals as long as you have access to
the formula but this program doesn't
give you that strong distribution you
don't have to I mean you don't have to
do it yeah yeah if you want you can do
it okay so what's the relevance of this
thing so you know if you have access to
two to a separation Oracle for your poly
tope and your polytope is coming from a
a uniform strong Rayleigh distribution
then it's it's sort of known that you
can actually get a vantage epsilon
approximation to this quantity that we
were trying to count as long as you
allow randomization okay so this is a
result of feather and me I you know it
this result has been extended to
non-uniform stronger ID measures as well
so you can even get the correct account
Minh when things are into uniform and
things aren't described by a polytope
anymore but this program is
deterministic it doesn't use
randomization and it gives you either
square roots or you know two to the rank
of your polytope approximation and just
last week I learned that there is some
evidence that this cannot be improved if
you if you only you allow determinism
okay so
this this evidence is not a proof
basically so so this work of Azhar
brooder and freeze what they show is
that if you want to count the number of
bases in a mate right and you only use
independence or a calls for that mate
roit which are equivalent to basically
the separation Oracle for the Metroid as
long as you don't allow determinism as
long as you do not allow randomization
you can't get better than this
approximation factor this is this
doesn't close the gap because this
convex program we haven't proved that it
works for any Metroid we have proved it
that it works for certain matrix coming
from stronger a distribution
but here is the open question so so you
know the only thing you need to solve
this convex program is the separation
Oracle for the convex hull for certain
matrix you might have it for certain
other polity ups you might have it and
you can always ask the question of how
well does this approximate the quantity
I'm trying to count the log of the
number of elements in my set okay
so what I just showed you was that if
this set was basically if the uniform
distribution on this set was a stronger
ID distribution then you have pretty
good approximations but you can ask this
for for other things for example if your
if your set is the set of perfect
matchings in a bipartite graph okay does
this what aprox what sort of
approximation does this give okay it's
sort of not hard to see that this still
gives you a very good approximation even
for bipartite matching okay
the reason is roughly that you know I I
told you that this part is very
unimportant okay this part is always
bounded by of n the 1 minus P log of 1
or 1 minus V part okay so if you throw
this away from your maximization problem
and instead you just maximize over this
part then what you get is the matrix
scaling algorithm first discovered by
with Gerson Apfel end
okay so so that relates to to basically
the vendor boredom conjecture what I'm
going to show you next is that this
thing still gives you an additive of an
approximation if your settee is the
intersection of two nice sets if your
set is the intersection of two two sets
whose uniform distribution is strong
your IV okay
so this sort of generalizes the the one
above I'm going to show you next how you
can write the bipartite matching as
intersections of two of these things so
n here is okay yeah good question
because I have to clarify here so here
I'm my my set is on 0 1 to the M n is
basically the maximum number of ones
that activity can appear in this set yes
entropy is zero but I'm saying that
that's what do you mean by one-sided so
if there is no perfect matching the
entropy is negative infinity I can I
can't distinguish between 2d and perfect
matchings and one perfect matching and
that's the best we know for for
deterministic algorithms actually so I'm
not breaking any of those
okay so a very nice open question here
is if you're if you're dealing with
general graphs not bipartite graphs you
can still write the same program and you
can hope that this gives you is still an
additive of an approximation to the
number of perfect matchings I should
mention that this is probably a very
hard problem because if you if you
resolve this in the positive then you
would have solved the lavash Plummer
conjecture which has been open for quite
a while so the lowbush Plummer
conjecture is there are there are
different versions of it
but the version I like the best is that
if you have a graph which is K regular
so every node has degree K and it's also
K connected so any way you you cut it
you you get at least K edges then the
number of perfect matchings in this
graph is going to be at least some
function of K to the N where this f of K
goes to infinity as K goes to infinity
so roughly roughly the reason that this
implies the lowest Plummer conjecture is
that if you have such a graph then the
vector of all one of our case is in the
matching polytope
if you put a 1 over K over all of the
edges you get a point in the matching
polytope and you know for that point
this entre P is going to give you Omega
of K to the end
but still I don't know of any counter
examples to this so this is a
generalization of the bluish Plummer
conjecture probably quite hard to
resolve yes it's been solved for K
equals 3 yes
so let me let me give you an overview of
what I've just said so there is always
this picture that I like to bring up
which is that these strong clear ID
measures are discrete counterparts to
these nice continuous distributions that
we that we love and those are the LOC
concave distributions okay why do I want
to bring up this picture it's because
there are a lot of similarities between
the two right
so from LOC concave functions you can do
efficient sampling from stronger ID
measures you can also do efficient
sampling that's the Markov chain
algorithm which is a generalization of
the feather my result that I talked
about you can also do maximization
approximately in these things so
forelock concave functions maximization
or finding the mode is equivalent to
solving a convex and concave program for
strong really measures Mohit talked a
bit a little bit about the some
particular version of it where this
strongly measure is a determinant of
distribution but basically the same
result holds when whenever whenever you
have any stronger idea measure with
access to its generating polynomial so
that's the result of Sascha so you know
you you have these distributions you can
do sort of efficient algorithmic things
with them but how can you build more and
more of such distributions well in the
lock concave case there are a lot of
operations that preserve la concavity in
the stronger I D case there are also a
lot of operations that preserve being
stronger lightly okay so here are some
of them so if you if you do an affine
transformation of a la concave function
you still get an la concave function if
you do symmetrization so you in the
stronger case you you basically collapse
two variables into one you still get a
stronger I distribution you can do
conditioning so
you condition on one variable having a
certain value in either case you were
still going to get the a distribution in
the same class
you can do margin ization so you sum
over all values in one direction okay so
so if you're if you think of random
variables associated to these
distributions marginalization is like
just dropping one of the variables so
this relates the subset question yes so
if you do marginalization you still get
you are still going to get this a
stronger idea distribution convolution
of these things is still going to give
you a distribution in the same class for
strongly measures it's sort of easy to
see why convolution gives you a stronger
ideal distribution it's because
convolution corresponds to multiplying
the generating polynomials so if
generating formulas have roots in
certain regions or don't have roots in
certain regions that's preserved by
taking the product there is one
operation which is sort of different
between the two and that's taking point
wise products so low concave
distributions if you take a point wise
product you're going to get the sum in
the log sum of concave function is
concave but for strong your idea
measures that's no longer true
the product of strong really measures is
not necessarily strong anymore but we
can still do basically the to
algorithmic operations that we wanted
approximately on the product so that's
what we proved if you have to strategize
distributions mu and nu you can compute
the you can compute an approximation to
the sum of the products or you can
compute an approximation to the maximum
of the product whichever you want so
that's counting that's optimization
the quality of the approximation is
still gonna be like before exponential
in basically the degree of the
polynomial or the maximum number of ones
appearing in the support of
distributions let's see what that means
in terms of some concrete problems so
bipartite matching so if you have a
bipartite graph and you want to count
the number of perfect matchings in it
you can write it as as a sum of products
of two stronger ID measures so the Mew
distribution is going to do the
following it's going to for each vertex
on the bottom side of the graph it's
going to pick one of its adjacent edges
uniformly at random the new distribution
is going to do the same thing for the
top side so so now the new distribution
only allows one edge adjacent to each
vertex on the top side mu satisfies that
for the bottom side if you take the
product you're gonna get the number of
perfect matchings because the only terms
that survive in this product are sets of
edges that have exactly that are
adjacent to that that basically
satisfied the degree constraints that
their degree on the bottom side and on
the top side are exactly one for each
vertex so that's one example of a
problem that you can solve using this
another example which I won't go into is
the so-called Nash social welfare it's
some some problem that that economists
are interested in and the discrete
version of it is quite hard to to solve
and based on these based on these sums
you can sort of get an approximation
algorithm for it
now I told you that you can get
approximations to the sum and the max I
didn't tell you how you get them okay
and I didn't tell you why the basic
problem that I told you the maximization
of the entropy and the intersection of
the
[Music]
so this maximization problem of things P
in the convex hull of two of these sets
I didn't tell you why this maximization
still gives you an additive of an
approximation so to show you this I have
to tell you what our inequality sells so
again as before we are gonna fix some
marginal vector this marginal vector is
now going to be both in both of these
two convex hulls so it's going to be
realizable for for both of my stronger I
D measures and now I take the maximum
relative entropy with respect to these
distributions so if you don't want to
think about relative entropy think of
these as sets and I take the entropy
itself so the entropy given by the
maximum entropy I can get with those
marginal and unset T 1 and T 2 so these
two things are the entropy I can realize
with the marginals P and the inequality
that we show is some sort of an entropic
inequality it says that the entropy of
the distribution I can get I get on mu
plus the entropy of the distribution I
get a new minus the sum of the entropies
I get under individual variables this is
a lower bound for the quantity that you
want log of the sum of the products
so so before before going further let's
see why this implies that this gives you
an additive of an approximation
so
you know I take this maximum and I want
to prove so certainly the maximum is
above the quantity that I want because
to entropy always upper bounds the
cardinality this thing is always bigger
than the sum of there
so the upper bound side is is true just
because of the subadditivity of the
entropy I just have to show you that the
lower bound side holds that this thing
is smaller than what I want plus some
additive oven yeah for the mew
distribution I have I have two
inequalities describing what this is
right I know that this thing is bigger
than the sum of P I log 1 over P I and
is that most the sum of P I log 1 over P
I plus this thing just based on the fact
that P is in the convex hull given by mu
distribution
for the new distribution I still get the
same thing okay now let's see so just
write that this thing is bigger than the
sum of the I log 1 over ple
if I add it to the same quantity for new
and subtract the entropies of the
marginals what do I get
well the entropies of the marginals have
two terms one of them is going to cancel
with what I was lower bounding this by
right so what I end up with is marginal
Zanu minus the sum of 1 minus P and I
log 1 over 1 minus VI
so this thing is all then as I said
before right and this thing is within
Levin of this thing
okay so so that sum of the entropies of
pis is in total is within o of n of the
lower bound I have proved on on this
quantity
so so in other words I've just shown you
that for any pies that are in both the
convex hulls this quantity is within
oven is lower bounding this quantity
within oven the upper bound part was
just the consequence of the
subadditivity of the entropy so I've
proved both sides of the inequality
questions on that
so what we also show is that this thing
is within ofd or sorry this should be n
o of n of the right-hand side basically
if from the entropies you drop the 1
minus P log 1 over 1 minus P terms you
get an upper bound of this thing I'm
going to give you some some intuition of
why that is so before going on I should
mention that you know these these
relaxations the relaxation that I showed
you is somehow built on some results of
corvatz that first use real stable
polynomials to use the Vandervoort than
conjecture there are also some other
relaxations by Nishat Vishnoi and damien
struts AK they also get some
approximations to exactly this quantity
and the max quantity their
approximations sometimes the chief
similar results sometimes they're linear
in M the number of variables as opposed
to the degree
so what I want to show you now is
[Music]
basically where this upper bound comes
from okay so this this quantity Plus D
is going to be an upper bound of this
I'm going to show you how how that upper
bound is drive so before actually
deriving the entropy inequality that I
mentioned in the previous slide we we
were dealing with a much simpler idea
that resulted in the inequality this
simpler idea is somehow dual to the
previous inequality somehow do all to
the convex program computing the
previous inequality but it's much
simpler to describe so I want to start
from scratch so so let's say that you
want to compute this sum of the products
this sum of the product looks like some
polynomial that you already have okay so
the generating polynomial of the MU
let's say already has the mutants in it
the the terms that the extra terms that
it has are just monomials in the zi
variables we we could hope that these
very equal to the new variables if we
could find setting of the zi such that
each monomial would be exactly new the
new the corresponding new coefficient
then i could just evaluate my power meal
at the sea-ice and get exactly the sum
of the products
well in general that's that's too much
to ask for so instead of an equality I
asked for an inequality so for each
monomial I ask that the monomial is
bigger than the new coefficient then
clearly if I find a setting of the Z
variables that satisfies this G mu value
that those Z variables is going to give
me an upper bound for my product of sum
of products
so you have a you have a clear way of
getting upper bound
what's the tightest way
what's the tightest upper bound that you
can get you can you can write it in as a
convex program okay so what you want to
do is you want to find the minimum of my
palm you'll over value Z 1 through Zn
such that the monomials for each
monomial kappa are upper bounding the
new variables the new values this convex
program this program can be turned into
a convex program if you just take the
the log of the variables and the log of
the objective function so it becomes a
geometric program for people who are
familiar with this but but the trouble
is still that I have potentially
exponentially many inequalities here one
for each monomial so I can't I can't
possibly hope that I can solve this but
there is a way of relaxing this further
to get a nicer convex program so instead
of instead of having this monomial
inequality I'm going to replace this
this new sorry this new variable by by
another quantity which is bigger than it
and then I'm going to require my Z
variables to be bigger than this relaxed
quantity so what is this relaxed
quantity so now I'm dealing with the
generating variable the generating
polynomial of the second distribution
the distribution new so any monomial
that you get Kappa I can compute this
ratio for it this this comes from works
of corvids
so let's say that all of the Kappas are
one okay then in the numerator I'm going
to get at least this monomial times nu
of Kappa and when I divide it by the
nominator I'm gonna get new of Kappa
plus some other positive terms right so
whatever I have in in here is bigger
than nu of Kappa okay that was for Kappa
which was equal to all ones but even if
you set some of the variables for some
of the Kappas to zero this thing is
still going to be bigger than nu of
Kappa that's not very hard to see and
again you have an upper bound for new of
Kappa what you can do is you can find
the best such upper bound that's
probably going to be a tight upper bound
and in fact where it's had already shown
that this gives you an an exponential
approximation to an off Kappa so there
is a this is tight up to an exponential
factor so so in some sense we don't lose
anything by replacing new of Kappa here
with this thing
so now instead of instead of requiring
that all monomials be bigger than new I
require that all monomials be bigger
than the relaxation of new right and I
even require it for even fractional
values of Kappa so it turns out that
this this whole thing is a cont is a
locked on K value in Capel's if you
treat them as fractional values and then
you can you can now solve or give a
separation Oracle for for all of the
inequalities of this form so so if you
if you do the diligence and write this
out and take the appropriate tool you
get this max min program okay so the
maximization is over all Kappas you
should think of these as the marginals
the minimization is over all y and z
variables which go into the polynomials
the generating communists and I'm
dividing by some appropriate monomial of
the Y and Z's okay how is this related
to the entropy thing that I was telling
you about well forget about new and
forget about the Z variables if if you
fix Kappas and you try to minimize the
ratio between jus G mu and the
appropriate monomial of Y eyes it's
exactly going to give you the entropy
the relative entropy of the best
distribution you can get with marginal
scalp eyes
there is a way that you can you can
actually remove these cap eyes from the
why eyes and you can move them outside
of the whole thing and so for the second
term you are gonna get the on the
relative entropy in the distribution you
once you remove the kappa eyes your the
thing that you're going to get here is
going to be basically this term the sum
of the entropies of the the marginals
and this shows that at least the upper
bound holds I won't have time to go over
the lower one unfortunately
so so let me conclude here so what I
just showed you was that you know
Australia really measures they exhibit a
a lot of similarities to la concave
distributions in the continuous world
you can maximize them you can
approximately you can approximately
maximize them you can approximately
count them you can efficiently sample
from them so on so one one very nice
open question here is you know this this
some we are currently getting an
exponential approximation factor for it
is there a is there a Markov chain that
you can run that gives you a 1 plus
epsilon approximation to this and this
is partially motivated by the fact that
when when these mu and nu give you the
bipartite matching we have such a Markov
chain due to JM st. Clair and we coda so
can you can you somehow generalize that
all such distributions we have hardness
results that show that you can't get
better than exponential approximation to
the max problem that's
this this simple sum of the marginal
entropies program
what polymers can you prove can you show
that it gives you a good approximation
to the corresponding counting problem
so this relates back to the non-uniform
distribution questions that you were
asking so so if you have a if you have a
set of the vertices of the hypercube
this convex program makes sense for for
counting that set but what if your set
is weighted what if you have crazy
weights on the set is there somehow an
analogue of the polytope maybe in some
higher dimensional space for which you
can still write this convex program and
get similar results and then finally I
think so this is an instance of this
more general problem can we can be
proved that the entropy program for
general matchings gives you a good
approximation and can be in fact used
stable polynomials to prove it time for
one or two questions
so these constraints you can do this the
product of disease Z to the power should
be at least your kappa he said the
founders that they're nice to mention
many of these put it you is somehow
nicely yes yeah generating for longer
range romaine so you have separation
yeah good question yes so let me go back
here
so the question is you know in general
this these are exponentially many
constraints and you can't generally hope
to have a separation Oracle for it but
let's say news r01 variables so so there
are basically the indicators of the
basis of a matrix let's say okay then
you can you can actually get a
separation Oracle here okay and you can
potentially get a tiger a proxy on backs
program so I mean are because this was a
relaxation of this you definitely get a
tighter value if you if you just do this
for matrix I think I know that says
sorry oh right yeah yeah
it's part of the counting racism
employed for these networks is it won't
be hard experiment is that you sure sure
sure
for spanning trees you can always count
it's not known to be hard for mate roads
that are whose uniform distribution and
stronger ivy it's known to be hard for
general matrix with deterministic
algorithms counting counting up
intersection intersection so it so good
question so that's just may trade
intersection
what I didn't tell you was that if you
have multi linear polynomials then their
support is always a the set of bases of
a matrix as long as they're homogeneous
material is always the intersection
ability the intersection thing is an
easy thing because of this convex
program I think if you have
sure so so for for general real save
Apollo meals the support is always a
jump system I think it's not true that
the intersection of two jumps at two
general jump systems can be checked to
be non-empty I think if you if you
assume that your coefficients here are
positive you you get jump systems that
are full and then you can maybe do it
not sure
just for clarity you're only dealing
with distributions over zero one right
or like where where the right so yeah
that's a good question so if so what I
what I talked about was only for
distributions over the hypercube but you
can you can have distributions over Z to
the N right for those you have some
corresponding sum of the products and
max of the products and you can still so
the reason I didn't talk about non zero
one values was that their sum sum
factorial some weird factors have to
come into play which are basically the
factorials of the powers so to keep it
clean I didn't go over there but still
you get some similar results so the
powers of disease becoming become bigger
integers but now the quantity you wanna
if you want to find is not just the sum
of the new kappa new kappa it's also you
have to multiply it by this weird thing
kappa 1 factorial
this is called the boom berry inner
product between I don't have to time to
go into the details of why these
factorials up here but
okay let's take remaining questions
offline and
I'm up here in session start at two
three
[Applause]